republicans are tough wholesome and for
small government
is not supported by the evidence he says
that americans have bought into these
fictions because republicans have run
very successful propaganda campaigns
that are echoed by right-wing media
outlets and accept it as truth by more
mainstream sources
the event hosted by olson's books in
washington d.c
is 75 minutes thank you very much
let me like to begin by um thanking
everybody for
coming here tonight um i'm actually at
the very beginning of my book tour
because the book was just released
yesterday
and as a result i'm still very
enthusiastic about attending events like
this and
talking about my book two weeks from now
i would be slightly less enthusiastic so
it's a good night and i am excited
to be here and start the discussion that
i i was hoping that the book would
provoke
one of the challenges that i have as
somebody who writes a daily column about
political matters
is trying to find the time to step back
and grapple with some of the issues that
are sort of perplexing when you write
every day you tend to write about the
things about which there's some degree
of certainty
and there's always questions that
perplexes you
that that perplexed you that you're
sometimes unable to really
examine in a deliberative way when
you're writing under the pressure of
churning out a column in essence every
single day and for me writing books
is an opportunity to take a step or
hopefully more
back and look at things from a broader
perspective
and try and grapple with some of the
questions that i think
are are difficult to answer and i've
tried with each of my books this is my
third one
to have the genesis of the book be some
question that i think is interesting and
important but at the same time difficult
to answer without thinking about
in a systematic and and thorough way and
for me
the question that prompted the current
book
that that we're here to discuss tonight
is
is
the following if if you look at polling
data
over the last several decades really
beginning with 1980 what you find is
a pretty decisive edge that democrats or
liberals or progressives have
in terms of pure policy positions that
is if you ask the american public what
their position is with regards to
specific policy questions
virtually across the board with very few
exceptions the public will
side with what the democrat or
progressive or liberal position is far
more so
than the conservative position despite
that fact
the conservatives the right wing in this
country have more or less dominated
our national elections over that same
say
30-year period over the last several
decades and
understanding that discrepancy why is it
that the political faction whose views
by and large are rejected by a majority
of americans
nonetheless has had such great success
politically in terms of our national
elections
it was something that i've been thinking
about for quite some time and is
actually not
all that easy to answer i mean it's it's
counterintuitive obviously one assumes
that the political faction with the
views that appeal to the most
number of americans would be the
political faction that would
attain the most success and and the
reverse has been true um
in our political culture and so what i
think that i found and and what i hope
that i make a good case for
in this book um is the explanation for
that discrepancy
and that explanation rests in the fact
that our elections are not determined
by a substantive consideration
of the weightiest issues that our
country faces but instead
are overwhelmed swamped with
all sorts of petty personality based and
kind of insipid themes that are
outcome determinative almost universally
and i think if if you go back from and
look at elections beginning in 1980
you see the same theme that we're seeing
right now
as of today i mean if you look at the
republican brand
right now it's probably never been more
sullied more discredited
as a result of the last eight years and
yet the candidate who is closely tied to
virtually every one of those radical and
destructive policies virtually no
deviation except in very minor cases
is someone who in virtually every public
opinion poll is either
tied with or slightly ahead of or
slightly behind
either of the two potential democratic
nominees
notwithstanding the fact that the
country overwhelmingly believes that
that political party has led the country
profoundly in the wrong direction
has led us into a recession has led us
into an unparalleled disaster
and occupation in iraq and across the
board is
deeply dissatisfied with the political
party that john mccain
is a part of and tied to and has
supported and yet
by all rights you ought to be behind 15
20 25 points in the poll and yet he's
he's in essence tied i mean that makes
no sense
if you operate on the premise that our
political elections are determined by
the citizens or eve citizenry view of of
political issues there was a
similar situation back in 1988 after
late years of the reagan administration
where
contrary to the way in which ronald
reagan has been canonized
the country was by and large very tired
of
and dissatisfied with reaganomics and
the republican brand of governing
and as a result when george bush the
first announced that he was going to run
for president he was something like 15
to 20 points behind
in every public opinion poll despite the
fact that his opponent was a fairly
unknown governor from
massachusetts michael dukakis and yet
that george bush
despite how tired and dissatisfied with
republicans the country was
ended up winning the election by a
fairly sizable majority and that's
similar to
um the path that we're on right now and
asking
and understanding why that is i think is
of the utmost importance
what happened in 1988 was that roger
ailes and lee atwater who were running
george bush the first campaign
understood that they were not going to
win
on the merits of the issues because the
country had soured on the republican
ideology
and so they decided very early on in
their campaign documents and memoranda
and insider accounts that demonstrate
that this is the case
that the election needed to turn on a
cultural
tribalistic personality grounded
framework
and that the idea was that george bush
the first would be built up
as this personality icon and michael
dukakis would be demonized
and those themes that were used very
successfully to do that
that dukakis was an elitist that he was
out of touch with
the common heartland values that he
waged war on and did not believe in
defining american principles that he was
weak that he was a loser that he was a
feat and capable of protecting americans
from criminals from foreign threats and
that george bush was this
combat hero who showed that he was
strong when he
defied dan rather in an interview and
started using
salty texan language that was foreign to
him but that he had been taught in and
that had been inculcated with him
really turned the election around and to
this day americans know about michael
dukakis virtually nothing about his
record
but they know that he looked like a
loser when he wore a helmet riding
around in the tank
and that he didn't show sufficient manly
rage when asked hypothetically what he
would do if his wife were
raped and murdered and similar instances
like that about that are purely grounded
in personality
were things that the american public
knew about michael dukakis and
recoiled from and that is the template
over and over and over and over
that the right has used successfully to
win elections
irrespective of what the public thinks
about
their substantive issues and that is
exactly the template
that they're gearing up to use today
this year it's their only chance to win
and you know one of the reasons why i'm
excited about the book being released
this week um is because i think that the
last couple of weeks have
illustrated this thesis as vividly as
anything i could have ever hoped for i
mean the book
examines not only these themes that the
right propagates but also
the media's critical complicity with
disseminating them
and ensuring that our elections are
decided by these themes
and if you look at the news cycles for
the past several weeks it's really
extraordinary
the issues that have dominated our
political discussions
it began about two and a half three
weeks ago when barack obama went
bowling in pennsylvania and he threw
gutter balls and was a horrible bowler
and the media decided that this
demonstrated that
uh he was someone who was out of touch
with the regular folk about whom the
media stars know
a great deal and then can speak for them
and
and because they're bowling alleys all
the time of course and and when barack
obama showed that he wasn't that showed
that he was some sort of exotic
bizarre elitist out of touch with
american values and therefore
unqualified to be president and that
theme was was knocked off the front page
and and off the pundit uh mind
only when obama gave his now famous
or infamous uh comments in in san
francisco which i don't know if you know
this or not that's the capital of
elitism
um in america he was in san francisco
and and he made his comments about
um religion and guns and and economic
insecurity and the relationship between
those those things
and literally it's been a week now where
the headlines are dominated by
discussions of these same themes we're a
country that
as i indicated is on the verge of if not
in a severe recession
has fundamental problems in terms of our
credibility our resources
our security our strength our political
values across the board profound
problems and yet none of those
are visible at all in in the way in
which the media
is covering these these events instead
what's happening is
um obama because it's presumed that
he'll be the nominee at the moment is
being attacked with these same
personality themes senator clinton when
she looked to be the presumptive nominee
or was assumed to be the nominee
by the pundit class and and by the right
was attacked with exactly the same sorts
of
uh tactics i mean it was is her laugh
indicative of some sort of soulless you
know satanic
power hungry almost inhuman um
evil that that is is culturally bizarre
and and there was discussion about
whether she had showed inappropriate
cleavage when she wore certain suits on
the four of the
senate whether or not she had a 20-year
plan to become president i mean the
types of petty issues
that a country enjoying great prosperity
and stability might be able to enjoy
wallowing in but a country that has very
real political problems
would have to be insane in order to
focus primarily or exclusively on these
issues and yet that
is the nature of our political culture
at the moment and so to me the the real
question the towering question is not
whether or not
what i just described is true i mean you
can demonstrate
scientifically with looking at media
stories that it's true
you can listen to what reporters say
about how they cover campaigns and the
way in which their affection personally
for a candidate
generates positive coverage and their
dislike of a candidate's personality
generates negative coverage
you can look at the fact that as i said
there's a huge discrepancy
between the political views of the
citizenry and the outcome of elections
to know that this dynamic
is what is the predominant dynamic and
how our our political elections are
decided the question
that i think is interesting and has to
be answered is what if anything
can be done to undermine that
and and that i think is a much more
difficult question um and
and ultimately i you know the answer
that i've arrived at and
and i'm fairly convinced that that it's
a persuasive explanation
um is it the reason that these
personality
themed attacks work is because they're
basically
one-sided attacks the republican or
right-wing candidate
is built up into this heroic icon and
the democrat or the liberal candidate
is demonized um as this sort of perverse
and very weak
even gender confused um elitist and and
and loser and that only one side is
engaging that battle
and like every battle like every debate
like every conflict when only one side
engages the battle and the other side
just sort of defensively tries to
ward it off but doesn't really ever
engage the side that's doing the
engaging
will always always always win and i
think that's what
has been happening and the problem is
that engaging this battle is
actually an easy task because
the iconography that the right uses to
build up their leaders
is not just petty i mean it is
incredibly petty i mean the idea that
um strength and moral probity and a
belief in
limiting federal government um in in
some sort of way that puts them in touch
with the regular folk
these are petty images but more than
headiness
is the fact that they're just completely
false
the leaders of the right-wing movement
who parade around
under the banner of these values
actually bear no resemblance
to those values in their lives and so if
they want to insinuate
this framework these metrics into our
political process
then i think it's important to engage
those metrics
talk about those attributes and put them
under that microscope
subject them to the same standards that
they themselves are advocating
in order to demonstrate that they do not
in any way
um exemplify those values that they
claim
um to to to exemplify and and you know
you can look at
across the board what these themes are
and and probably the most significant
one
is the idea that republicans and
republican leaders are
strong and courageous and democrats are
weak
and irresolute um and what that has come
to mean
in in our political culture is that the
republicans
like war they like to start wars they
like to send other people off to war
they like to continue the wars once
they've begun they think that bombing
other countries is
a good way to advance policy goals that
it's exhilarating
um and that it by cheering on war by
believing in war
and an aggressive and belligerent
foreign policy one can
demonstrate strength that's how you show
that you're strong
by the converses is that also true that
that if you oppose war or you believe
that war is something
that ought to be avoided except in those
extremely rare circumstances where where
it cannot be if you believe in
alternative methods to resolving
america's
disputes and fulfilling its goals
besides war then that means in essence
that you're weak or cowardly or or
somehow
a resolute the reality of course is that
there's nothing strong or courageous
about deciding that other people are
going to be sent off to war
um and yet that premise is virtually
never
challenged one of the the examples that
i use in the book is that
george bush the first um when he first
ran
decided that he was going to run for
president was was dogged by
by rumors that that he was actually a
wimp
and newsweek actually published a cover
when he announced that he was going to
run for president
that announced that he had to battle the
wimp factor
even though he was a combat hero in
world war ii he had trouble maintaining
that that image of strength
and in in the first year when he was in
office
he ordered the us military the most
powerful military even then
to invade a tiny and and defenseless
country that could not in any way
threaten us or attack us panama
um we killed several thousand panamanian
civilians we don't
count them and we don't know exactly how
many we killed but roughly in that area
and the very next day the new york times
ran a front page article by r.w apple
the new york times reporter
declaring that bush had finally shed his
wimp image
because he fulfilled the rite of passage
that all american
presidents have to fulfill in order to
prove that they're strong which is a
willingness as he put it
to shed american blood just essentially
a symbolic way of demonstrating that he
was a strong leader
was the fact that he was willing to
start war as long as that premise
remains in place
and there's no discussion of the fact
that there's nothing strong or
courageous about sending other people
off to war
and that it's often infinitely stronger
and more courageous
to argue against war or to impede war or
to stop stupid and destructive wars
um then this theme will simply continue
it would have to because the premise is
being
unchallenged and if it's unchallenged
the party that's always the most pro-war
party the hawkish most hawkish party
will always be perceived as the strong
party
and the party that tends to oppose war
at least marginally more so
will be perceived as the weak party the
other
aspect of this strong weak dichotomy
that i think is worth highlighting
is the fact that the greatest
misconception
that democrats and progressives and
liberals especially in washington have
had for a very long time
is that the reason republicans are
perceived as strong
is because they believe in this hawkish
foreign policy and that's strong
and therefore in order for liberals to
avoid appearing weak
what they need to do is to replicate
that
approach as much as possible almost to
the point where they become carbon
copies of it in order to eliminate
this discussion from the political arena
and then the
elections can focus on what they
perceive to be their strong points
whether that's economic security or
social programs
and the like the reality is exactly the
opposite of the advice that they've been
getting and of the
path that they've been taking for for
decades now
um michael dukakis when he first ran for
for president
had the advice of susan estrich who told
him
that the most important thing that he
could do was to immediately abandon
the label liberal and insist that he was
not a liberal at all even though it
really seemed like as governor of
massachusetts he was the standard
classic liberal in every single possible
way
that he had to convince the american
public that liberal was not anything
that he
was like instead he was simply a
competent technocrat
and since then democrats and
progressives have been characterized
largely by the behavior where they
apologize for their own belief system
they run away from the obligation to
defend and advocate those beliefs
those beliefs because they believe that
those beliefs are what make them appear
weak
the reality is it's the running away
from those beliefs
the unwillingness to take a stand for
what their political values really are
the fact that they lack the courage of
their convictions
that is what has made them look weak in
the eyes of americans for so long
and that's something that republicans on
the right have long understood
um there's a whole litany of of
issues where the right has taken
positions
that were extremely unpopular among
american citizens
impeachment for example every single
poll showed that overwhelmingly
americans thought that impeachment was a
bad idea
and yet republicans pursued it
unapologetically to the very end
if you look now at the iraq war the iraq
war is probably the single most
unpopular war in american history if not
the most unpopular war and yet there
have been virtually no defections
in the republican steadfast
steadfastness of supporting that war
and of opposing withdrawal even though
it's politically unpopular because they
embrace their position
and they stick to it until the end and
that is what makes them look strong
not the specific policies by contrast
what you have are democratic strategists
telling democratic politicians
that to oppose the war will make them
look weak because war opposition
is a sign of weakness and therefore they
can't really follow through on what it
is that they think
they can't really stand up to the
president in the realm of terrorism
or in the realm of war because to do so
will leave them open to charges of being
weak and so they constantly equivocate
and they apologize for what their
positions are and they take tepid
stances
rather than taking clear stances that
are based on
political principle and americans see
them equivocating and see them afraid
to take their own positions and it's
then that they look weak not when they
advocate
their positions and political values but
when they are afraid to
and so until this changes until this
dynamic changes
um you know george bush stan stood up in
in the 2004 republican national
convention acceptance speech
by which time he was already an
unpopular incumbent by which time the
iraq war was already unpopular
and the defining line of that acceptance
speech was
you may not always agree with me but
you'll always know
where i stand that was the way in which
george bush tried to present
a image of strength not by taking
positions
that he thought that americans liked but
by telling americans
that he would stand firm in support of
his values
that is what ultimately strength is
about not that george bush really did
that but that he cast that perception
that he was doing that and that's
something that democrats for so long
have
have failed to do the other themes and
i'll just be much more
uh concise and and describe these in
summary fashion and then open it up
um to questions um are even easier to
address i mean the idea that republicans
stand for
the values of mainstream americans or
traditional marriage when
virtually the entire top level of the
political leadership
lives private lives that couldn't be any
further removed from
those traditional values that they claim
to embrace the idea that the republican
party
is the party of limited government and
standing against government intervention
and in favor of individual autonomy
and the right of regular americans to
live their lives free of government
intervention
when over the last eight years and
during the reagan years the government
has ballooned
in its in the scope of its power um in
in its spending
and in the reach that it has into the
lives of american citizens
we are a country that over the last
eight years has
vastly expanded the national security
state
the surveillance state the power of the
president to collect data about what
americans do in their private lives to
listen in on them
to read their emails listen to their
conversations without warrants of any
kind without checks
the idea that this is the party of
limited government is laughable
on its face and yet that premise too
is is never challenged and so the
right wings tactics um are are
effective and they're dishonest the
dishonest part
is something that ought not to be
replicated even if it's politically
expedient to do
but the effective parts even when
they're petty
and lowly and distract from what the
issues
of that our country needs to face are
is something that needs to be directly
engaged and that hasn't happened yet
and the reason it needs to be directly
engaged is not because
we want to take both sides and drag it
down into the muck even further
it's because unless those tactics are
engaged and directly addressed
they're going to continue to be
effective they're going to continue to
exclude
a consideration of substantive issues
from our political process and so the
idea of engaging them
and not allowing right-wing leaders to
build themselves up as these absurd
laughable deceitful caricatures is not
about joining the right down in the mud
it's about neutralizing those tactics
rendering them impotent
so that the election and our political
discourse no longer can be
decided in this unilateral way down in
the mud
but then we'll have to shift out because
now those tactics are being neutralized
into more substantive areas and at the
very least
to stop this deceit where right-wing
leaders prance around is
everything except what they really are
while
demonizing and destroying the character
um of
any democratic or progressive or or
liberal candidate and ensuring
um that our elections are are won by a
political faction
that espouses views that that are
rejected by
the overwhelming preponderance of
americans and that's been happening for
several decades and
i think there's no greater challenge
especially now
than finding a way to to stop that and
to reverse it and my book is an effort
to
ask how that can be done and propose
some potential
solutions so with that um let me thank
you again very much for
for coming tonight and i'm happy to take
questions or
comments um
um thank you very much for the talk and
um
a couple things uh barack obama has been
the recipient lately by his democratic
opponent of some personality attacks and
the way he's responded
seems unique for denver you know from
candidates in the past and at the
present time they don't seem to be
sticking in the way
you know they might have um could you
just address how
he may be different in that way and how
he and i think part of it is is that he
does
hone to his principles he never gives in
so in a way he's not
yielding his identity to the attacks
which is what a lot of democrats have
done in the past so
but if you could talk address that in
terms of how he might fare in the
general election
and then the other part is
progressive talk radio has
many of the progressive talk hosts have
been
um not only going after the policy uh
differences that they have
with john mccain but they are starting
to do
some of that personality they're trying
to turn the tables by doing some of that
personality
stuff on there so i was wondering if you
could talk about those two issues in
terms of their impact
those are both both great questions
thank you um the with regard to the
first i mean i've written
several times about some exemplary
responses
that i think obama has given to some of
these attacks one in particular really
struck me
um which was when uh really obama had
had pretty favorable media coverage
um up until the point that it seemed
like he actually might win um
and and it was really once the the
prospect that he might win
um really sunk in with a lot of people
did did this all
start getting unleashed and one of the
very first um
signs of this was the controversy over
the fact that he wouldn't wear his lapel
pin
um and and that kind of picked up steam
right around the time that his wife had
said
um that this was the first time that she
was really proud of the political
process
um in this country and all of these
things were being sewn together
to suggest that he hated america um and
you know that too is a standard of an
attack as
as it gets ever since um you know the
whole demonization of jimmy carter and
michael dukakis and his card-carrying
aclu membership and
and his pledge of allegiance position
and things of that nature
um and obama what's what politicians
typically do in those situations is if
they're caught not wearing a lapel pin
um you know they'll run to put as many
american flags around themselves every
single time they speak as
as possible and and they'll be sure to
sing you know patriotic songs every time
there's a camera nearby and what obama
did was the opposite
um he said yes i i've refused i'm not
wearing lapel pin anymore
because i think these are cheap displays
of patriotism
and i think americans know that
patriotism isn't
demonstrated by how many lapel pins you
wear instead i'm eager to have the
debate
over what real patriotism is and i want
to have that debate with the party
that has dragged us into this
destructive war and has dismantled our
constitutional values
and unraveled everything that has always
made america great in terms of our
political values that was a perfect
um response because he refused to
to accept the premise that he needed to
be on the defensive and then he went on
the attack
offensively and said let's talk about if
patriotism is going to be the metric
they want to inject
let's talk about how that really ought
to be applied and that's exactly the
type of thing
that i'm talking about needs to be done
a lot more having said that
um you know i think it really remains to
be seen
whether or not the idea that you can
really kind of remain above these sorts
of attacks
and not engage in them
bilaterally is something that can be
sustained for a long period of time
americans will tell you if you ask them
that they don't want these drudge-like
personality attacks
playing any role in our political system
and yet every time
they do they end up having a great
influence on the outcome of the election
why is that
because these kind of attacks even
though they're petty are really potent i
mean they trigger
important cultural and psychological and
tribalistic
identifying impulses and so once there's
really a democratic nominee
the right-wing noise machine and all of
its slimy appendages and
and all of their media partners are
really going to gear up
whether the nominee is hillary clinton
or barack obama and it's going to be
extremely ugly because it's their only
chance to win
is to be that ugly even uglier than
normal and
when there is that degree of an assault
that's that coordinated
and the candidate who is the target of
it is refusing in essence to return
fire along the same lines i think it
remains to be seen
whether or not even those sort of more
elevated and
and emphatic responses will be will be
sufficient
i don't see how an election can be won
no matter what people think of john
mccain's economic mastery or his view on
iraq
if he's allowed to be depicted as
this honor-bound upstanding
post-partisan
man of principle and the other candidate
is
you know a radical ally of the weather
underground who
is essentially a muslim terrorist um and
a um
black christian radical at the same time
who hates america
um you know those are potent themes and
if that really is the framework that's
going to take root
i'm not sure it's going to matter much
what the rest of of the issues are i
think there's a threshold
an equalizing point that has to be
reached before
the issues can start to matter as much
as they ought to
as far as you know what you asked about
progressive radio and other things there
are
um instances where people are talking
about mccain's personal life and saying
things like if you want to talk about
you know what really is is the character
of a person
you know let's talk about the fact that
when he returned from vietnam and found
his wife who was
you know in a near fatal car accident
raising his children and
as a result of that accident was
debilitated and several
inches shorter and many many pounds
heavier and when he returned and saw
that he almost immediately began
having adulterous affairs and finally
found a woman who was much much younger
and much much prettier and
much much much much much richer
and he then dumped his wife and and his
children didn't talk to him for several
years as a result and he married that
woman whose family wealth then fueled
his political uh career and kept him in
the lap of luxury this man of of
of the regular people for the last three
decades
then i think those things ought to be
discussed because if they're not there's
going to be this one-sided
framework the problem is that there is
nothing comparable to the right-wing
noise machine i mean progressive radio
is a tiny tiny fraction
um and and there's not that partnership
forged with the establishment press at
the right wing
more and more in the mainstream media's
questions it's getting better
but but it's still nowhere equal yep um
all right two questions here first of
all isn't when you said that there was a
one-sided
fight and it is a one-sided fight but
it's really kind of two forces
as not only in the right-wing machine
but
the corporate media who joins the
right-wing
machine is it also in their economic
interest
through to pursue their own media
consolidation
and you know to inflate their own
salaries and money and all that
to be attacking uh the democratic
candidate where the
candidate is and second question the
primary has produced record number of
primary voters within the democratic
states did will that is that
signify anything in the future as we
head to the general
election right as far as the media is
concerned there's obviously
all sorts of motivations as to why the
establishment press has been hostile to
the democratic candidate
and and and far more favorable to the
republican candidate some of it is
personality based
some of it is cultural some of it is is
this sort of peer pressure
some of it is the fact that they're
dependent on power and power has been
republican power
um for the last 15 years and some of it
is ideological interest
embedded in corporate ownership um
regardless of what the motivations are
that's just a fact
the establishment press is that way um
you can
sort of sit back in resignation and say
well the cards are are the deck is
stacked against us um because the
establishment press hates us and loves
them
um or you can say we understand that
obstacle and need to perfect and improve
our strategies
um for how to get our message for how to
get better control of our messaging
notwithstanding those obstacles shaming
individual reporters shaming individual
news outlets
having people who are are democrats and
progressives who get media attention
articulate these messages
raising lots of money and having smart
and aggressive campaigns
aimed at destroying john mccain's
character if they're destroying barack
obama and hillary clinton's character
in an honest but a a an aggressive way
are all things that can be done to
circumvent that even if they don't
completely mitigate that that
disadvantage
so yeah that obstacle is there but it
doesn't mean that it has to be as
one-sided
um as it's been as far as democratic
intensity it's obviously much greater i
mean the country hates republicans i
mean they just do
and they hate the war and they hate
economic management and they hate george
bush and dick cheney they hate
everything about the republican party
that you can't ask for
a more discredited and toxic brand um
than the republican party is right now
and that's why john mccain just like
george bush did in 2000
is running as a different kind of
republican and someone who
deviates from his party and pushes them
away the reality is he doesn't
and especially on the issues that have
caused americans to hate that party
he's one of the the most loyal foot
soldiers for it and so
um yes there is that intensity but
the poles um aren't reflecting this
advantage and i think the reason is what
i
uh started off by by disgusting which is
that mccain is built into this
um sort of venerated figure um while
hillary clinton and barack obama
almost without the help of the press and
the right right now are tearing each
other down and doing the work for for
the republicans and that's only going to
get much much worse
um yeah in the back there um i
agree with a lot of what you're talking
about as far as the fact that image
politics seems to be driving
the debate in our country but i think
that one of the things that i'd like you
to address that i haven't really hear
you talk about that much yet is the fact
that
although you know the country is furious
and we're all very very angry and
everybody's
you know we're upset with the war we're
upset with everything else um you know
the economy is doing terribly that there
doesn't seem to be a lot of action
on the part of the public and i see more
apathy than i see
um anybody trying to drive this i mean
the fact that you know obama's bullying
and his like most recent comments are
driving what's in the media right now as
opposed to
the things that are going on with
torture and iraq war
itself um i mean is there any do you
think that it's just that the media is
so powerful that
you know the normal people can't drive
what's going on
or i mean in my eyes it just seems that
there's so much apathy right now because
i don't even know what um that that's
really causing
the problems rather than and that's
what's allowing image politics rather
than policy
to be driving what's going on in the
country yeah i mean that's a hard
question to answer
both in general and in this kind of a a
format um given
time constraint and the like um and and
even if you had all the time in the
world it's a hard question to answer
um why why is there so much apathy when
when there ought to be virtually none
um i think the primary factor to the
extent that there is this pervasive
apathy that you're describing
is the fact that people have given up on
the idea um that there's anything that
they can do that actually matters
that the behemoth of the beltway
political and media establishment is so
enormous
and so removed from anything that they
can affect that there's a resignation
in essence um and and when obama tried
to explain his comments in
in the capital of elitism that's
essentially what he said which is
that what he means is that the reason
why that kind of
that kind of um anger makes people move
into the cultural realm away from
political realm is because they stop
stop believing that the political
culture can never really do anything for
them
having said that i think it's important
not to overstate the the extent of the
apathy
this gentleman was just pointing out
that there's been unprecedented
amount of participation in democratic
primary enormous numbers of new voters
for once the youth vote is actually
showing the promise that that has been
touted for it
um there's enormous amounts of money
that are being raised from from small
donors even in times of economic
difficulties
where people obviously feel like it's
critically important to do what they can
to change the political culture the
growth of online
activism and blogs i think is another
indication where hundreds of thousands
of people
every single day in their spare time
instead of you know sitting on their
couch and watching
crappy television are turning on their
computer and choosing to read you know
detailed discussions
of bills before subcommittees and and
how to effect change in
in our political system so um yeah
there's more applicants than it ought to
be
um but i think it's it's diminishing as
a result of
this anger towards the political class
yep
it seems to me that the republicans
understand something that we as
democrats
unfortunately do not and i'd like you to
comment
on it and that is that as a species
we're not homo sapiens
all of our discussion about policy this
and policy that is predicated
on the concept that we're homo sapiens
we're not doing the same things
what drives us is emotions all of us
in all of our majors that's what the
republicans work on
they work on the idea of pushing
people's emotional buttons
and we as democrats i think need to
understand that
and our dialogue our framing etc
has to be built upon that concept that
we're not homeless atheists
it doesn't matter your ten point plan on
this order twenty point ten on that
and the person that i think has gotten
closest to this is in the
in the book of the political brain
and i think we would all be much much
better off
if we you know took what he is saying to
heart and
and and also recognize that this concept
of homo sapiens
is a recent construct of its policy
right i mean you know i think
i think that's an important observation
um although uh i think it only takes you
so far because
uh there are all sorts of ways to
package uh emotionally appealing
messages
you can speak about 10-point policy
plans
and inspire all sorts of emotions if you
talk about
the ways in which they lift people up
and the way that in which their lives
are improving the way in which it
elevates
the national interest you can talk about
you can trigger strong emotional
responses
if you engage in uh personality um
building or personality
destruction or triggering some of these
themes so i think you're absolutely
right that
one of the things the republicans have
done far better is tap into these
emotional reservoirs that that
influence even the most rational uh
among us
um and and um i think there's a
squeamishness on the part of democrats
and liberals over
the idea that well dealing with emotions
um
is sort of manipulative and it's much
more noble
and elevating um to stay above the fray
and and strictly speak about
matters in a rational manner you can be
passionate and you can trigger emotions
and still speak the truth and still talk
about policy
um in a very insightful and noble way so
they're not mutually exclusive and
and i think you're right though there is
this sense that um
packaging political messaging in a way
that's designed to trigger
passion um is somehow untoward and i
agree that that needs to be abandoned
think about if dukakis had answered that
question how most of us
in this room would hopefully would have
answered that question
and how different things would have been
i mean it was it was dishonest the way
he answered it was dishonest
yeah i mean i think if we look at this
the campaigns you've been talking about
just since we talked about that
okay we're often our campaigns of
democratic campaigns are often run by
lawyers
and no reflection on you because you're
a lawyer
you know um bush one had at order and
push two
karl rove and and so i think that
axelrod
is from the heartland i think and i
think that obama has shown
that he can run a good campaign so i i
feel more comfortable and i just
i don't want to get into this black and
white we're good they're bad i don't
and i don't think that we're going to
sell that a mccain i mean he has a
different approach to global warming he
has a different approach to immigration
he granted immunity
to other issues so no but the point is
you're going to go out into middle
america that's we people on the coast
have to stop thinking about why the
republicans are evil
and thinking we needed to be guided in
my opinion because i'm an obama
supporter
by obama and he's building a broad
coalition
and it's not going to be gun control
pro-choice et cetera et cetera
right it's going to be all of america
that's what he's trying to do
right so i just think that we need to
get away from this
right-wing evil stuff right i don't
think the issue is
right-wing evil i think the issue is
that if the right advances arguments
about who and what they are that are
false
that they need to be rebutted and i
think that if the right advances
arguments about who and what democrats
and progressives are
that those need to be rebutted as well
and so you know i think the idea that
you're describing
is not a new idea in the sense that for
the most part
democratic campaign consultants have
essentially believed in
exactly what you're describing which is
we need to get away from this divisive
rhetoric
we need to show that we're not going to
be as combative and as absolute
as the right wing we need to show that
we're actually much more towards the
middle
and and and what that's done is often
times it's muddled things and it's made
the democrats
unwilling to take on debates and and
arguments and fights
that the right was actually pursuing in
an ideal world
you know i think you're absolutely right
that it would be really nice if we just
all sort of came together and even when
we disagreed on political issues we
could all sit down and
and in a very civil and constructive way
work those out that would be
the ideal thing but wishing that that
were so or saying that you're going to
abide by those rules
even when the other side isn't i think
is a recipe for
for defeat and i think that's what uh
the last 30 years
have demonstrated so i just say that
just remember
obama's consistently said talked about
wages and all kinds of other progressive
issues
so and and as somebody else said he
sticks to his guns
so yeah that was me i said that i mean i
think
it's very clear that his his point is on
style
and some people have criticized him on
the right they're saying that
he's trying to sound nice but he's
really a liberal so i i think that he is
again if you don't build a coalition in
the united states you don't win
elections
especially if you're a democrat tell us
right i think the question is how to
build the coalition i think everyone
is in favor of coalition building yeah
yeah one of the most telling
incidents it was kind of lost in the
obama bowling week
was when the republicans pushed back on
the mccain hundred years in iraq and and
you had the usual suspects mark halperin
politico
like allen whoever said actually you're
right you know i don't know if he said
this i
you know and they basically jump to
mccain's defense
so my question is even if democrats push
hard on it
do you think that given mccain's love
fest with the media that
they would turn on him or is it going to
be a constant
media and republicans defending mccain
from here to november
well you know i think shame is a very
important tool
in in the arsenal when it comes to
changing media behavior
um because no matter how nefarious your
perception of journalists might be no
matter how
um you know sort of you can take the the
more generous
uh view that that basically they do what
they do because they're basically kind
of empty and and easily led people who
aren't very smart
um and and who have this you know sort
of adolescent um
mentality that guides them or you can go
to the opposite extreme and say no
they're they're tools of of their
corporate masters who
um you know get dictates implicitly and
explicitly to advance an ideology
whatever it is at the end of the day
they're still human beings who respond
to all the things that
normal and regular human beings do and
they don't go into work thinking about
themselves
as um you know sort of one-sided tools
who are in the tank from a king that's
not how they think of themselves they
don't want to think of themselves that
way
and so if you can marshal the forces to
make them realize that that's what
they're doing or to make them feel like
people are thinking that about them
they will start to compensate not all of
them some of them to varying degrees
but there is a sense already that's out
there that they know that there's this
perception that
um they revere mccain that they're
uncritical when
when it comes to him and so i think that
behavior can be changed um
to some degree that way i saw your
blogging heads
with anna marie jackson i've read her
since the
infamous barbecue when halley bailey's
on the
tiger drinking wine or whatever wine
yeah
whatever it was i mean i don't she might
it seemed like she was more offended
than anyone had the gall that questioned
her
her integrity and she didn't seem to
think that she was on the table right i
mean just because you spend weekends at
the home of the person you're covering
isn't any reason to think that you would
be
you know unfavorable too favorable or
incapable of being objective i mean i
don't know why anyone would
would think that and that seemed to be
her point yep
i think that what happens is the media
person who likes john mccain
doesn't go the step further yeah that's
right he said 100 years but he met like
in japan or germany
where nobody's being shot nobody's being
killed but the
question that's begged i think is well
we're not there yet in iraq
how long is it going to take us to get
there before
the hundred years clock starts you know
right and they won't ask him that
well because they like it i think well
yeah i think one of the most telling
examples has been
how the media works has been
when mccain was going through the middle
east with his middle eastern adviser joe
lieberman
and he was yeah and he was he out of the
blue just all of a sudden
on multiple occasions in various
different venues started accusing iran
of training al-qaeda operatives inside
iran and then sending them back into
iraq something which
i don't think even bill crystal claims
is true or maybe he does but
virtually nobody else um and and joe
lieberman whispered in his ear that he
didn't really mean that and without
thinking he mindlessly repeated what joe
lieberman had whispered in his ear and
said i don't mean that i meant they're
training shield extremists
um and and uh
really there were two distinct
possibilities that otto had been
explored either he had no idea what he
was talking about about the most basic
matters in his area of great expertise
which is
i don't know if you know this foreign
affairs and national security mccain's
an expert in that
or he was engaged in the kind of deceit
that the bush administration has
perpetrated for the last eight years of
linking whoever the enemy of the week is
to al-qaeda
um this is the country or the faction
that we hate did you know that they're
working with al qaeda
yeah or well that was ultimately what
they decided that they they wanted to go
with because that was that was the
the the sort of most benevolent but um
what the media decided and i'm not
you shouldn't think this because i'm
saying that this is what i think they
were doing
they you should think that this is what
they were doing because they said that
this is what they were doing
is they essentially decided it wasn't a
story because they know that mccain
really
knows a lot about the middle east so it
couldn't be that he was mistaken
um and they also know about him that
he's a really honest
guy he's an honor bound man of principle
he's a straight talker
and so it couldn't be that he was
deceiving either it must have just been
a sort of
bizarre um slip of the tongue that
repeated itself
four times in exactly the same way in
the course of a week um
and and so they have this under belief
about who john mccain is about his
character
that really precludes them from
reporting on him in an adversarial way
because they think that if you have
something
that reflects negatively on him on his
character
by definition it must be false because
his character is upstanding and good
and that is you know the real um
challenge is
is to figure out how to overcome that um
yeah we'll take a couple more
and then yep you called out a couple of
pretty high profile journalists on your
blog
and for you know lame interviews or
whatever and
they seem to respond very vehemently
that you're full of it
and they're very objective and books do
you think
do you think they really meant that were
they defensive what do you think
yeah i mean i think journalists and and
you know my my
perception of journalists is is based on
my observations of them and my
interaction with them
um are unbelievably thin skinned i mean
they
hate to be criticized it really bothers
them even
you know there are times when i mention
a journalist
literally in passing because i'm i'm
quoting something that just happens to
include his or her name
and i'll get an email from them you know
vehemently objecting to
the horrible personal attack that i
waged on
and then when i hadn't even realized
that i had even mentioned that i mean
they were literally quoted in passing
and yet you know i have noticed um that
when
journalists are uh are targeted for that
kind of criticism
they do start modifying their behavior
even subconsciously one of the things
that anna marie cox had said in that
that
blogging head's discussion that i had
was out of the blue she started in this
lengthy confessional slash testimonial
about how
her writing is suffering because now
whenever she goes to write something
she thinks about whether or not it's
going to provoke
liberal bloggers to gang up on her as
she put it
and that she finds herself suppressing
the things that she'd want to say
whenever she fears that that will happen
to me that seemed like a really good
thing
she was saying it like it was some grave
loss to journalism like liberal bloggers
are destroying journalism because
they're making journalists think twice
about whether or not what they're saying
is actually true or or persuasive to me
that seemed like a good thing
and so i do think that it is having that
effect
um like i said you know some are
probably impervious to it some are too
pompous to to care
others are too set in their ways but for
many many journalists the more you pound
at them about these behaviors
the more they'll think twice when
engaging that behavior the next time and
i think that's one of the most effective
tools
um yet in the back there i'd just like
to get your take on
what seems like a virtual media blackout
on the uh torture meetings that
just came out recently were changing
rights and all together
and deciding what torture we were
actually going to use
i'm just stunned yeah you know i mean
the only thing i'd say about that is
whenever you think that the immediate in
this country
has reached the floor and that they just
can't go any lower that that's not
possible they always find a way
to go lower usually a lot lower um
and this that i mean it is shocking that
part i always think that i've i've
actually steeled myself to
to this reality and yet every time i see
it i'm i'm amazed by it i mean
that what what else can one say about
this i mean it really was just revealed
conclusively that the president united
states
and almost all of his top aides sat
around
planning down to the detail what are by
all
measures illegal methods of torture i
mean there's just no other way to
describe it
um and yet it barely created
you know a ripple i mean it just didn't
i i
mentioned a couple days ago that i
rarely watch you know cable news except
when i'm traveling i'm in a hotel and
kind of just subjected to it
inadvertently and i don't think i
you know i flip through all the channels
continuously for a few hours on several
occasions i literally don't think i
heard a single
time those matters being
discussed i mean john you the memo that
he wrote that was recently disclosed
literally said in it um you know in a
footnote
as you know in a recent memorandum we
concluded
that the fourth amendment to the
constitution of the united states is
inapplicable
to quote domestic military operations
inside
the united states i mean that is a
declaration that the u.s government
suspended the bill of rights in secret
um and i i really i read a few articles
on it on you know a couple ap articles
on it maybe a couple
uh short new york times in washington
post articles and other than that i mean
there was no
discussion of it whatsoever and i can
guarantee you that you know and there'll
be polls that will show this
eventually that probably 20 to 30 times
more americans will know
about we'll know that barack obama
balled at 38. i don't even think he
pulled a 38 but that's what
the meet 37. um i'm in i'm in the
ignorant minority there
but but we're going to know that that he
he bowled that that score
then we'll know that um the president of
the united states and his top aides
met to choreograph um how torture was
going to be used or that the fourth
amendment to the
uh constitution the bill of rights had
had been suspended i mean those facts
just to me speak for themselves
about that the democratic leadership i
mean
among others
even if we acknowledge that these more
visceral issues like bowling spores or
what people drink in bars is is of
greater interest to the press and
perhaps more attractive to the public
issues do get into the news there's
certain things that people talk about as
issues
there's one that i don't see getting
very much attention at all and i think
particularly in light of
this question about these recent
discussions of torture that were
disclosed
i'm very interested to know how any of
these candidates would choose a cabinet
how they would how they would seek
advisors i mean i'd like to know who but
that's not even that important at this
point and we never hear about that
um i would be interested to know why you
think that's the case is it too much
political liability to bring other
personalities in
is it um just not interesting to the
press
you know i mean it's it's a good
question i mean who one's cabinet
members are going to be is obviously a
significant
uh part of what kind of president a
person um will be i don't know if it's
too early and and
that those questions don't get answered
i don't know if candidates don't like to
answer those questions until they know
whether the person is interested or and
i doubt very many candidates think
very extensively about that i've heard a
little bit about it i think
some candidates have said uh that they
would consider putting people like you
know barack obama or richard luger or
people like that in their cabinet
um
that gets to the candidate and they have
to comment yeah i mean i'm not sure how
substantive that is
precisely for the reasons that i just
identified i mean i think even that gets
into
this sort of politics as celebrity you
know colin powell
um might be the new you know secretary
of defense or is condi rice going to be
uh vice president that stays on the
level of celebrity
like chatter and and i don't think it
goes you know very far
um can the democrats or progressives
overcome the situation described without
a serious investment in media
just one example with a relatively minor
investment by al brin
i mean they're everywhere and it just
seems to me that
a lot of money has been raised for this
campaign but virtually nothing has been
raised for alternative media we spend a
lot of money
to our cable networks but our cable
providers and we have not a single
channel that we can go
and get anything like box or we get
maybe an hour two hours a day from ms
nbc and they have to balance it with the
five shows for every one that olbermann
has that the ratings are equal
right i i don't really see you
talk all the time about you know we have
to deal with the media or try and
convince them but it would be so much
more effective to me look at [ __ ]
to spend some money and have an
alternative i agree
it's a great point um and and i think
not only fox but but right wing radio
the entire industry of right-wing
authors who are who are subsidized and
and always um have uh the guarantee that
huge numbers of their books will be
purchased to inflate their sales figures
to make them look like successful
authors which then results um in them
going on
all sorts of shows um so i think that
there are
factors outside of the control and
and culpability of progressives that are
obstacles but i think there are things
that
could be done by opponents of the right
wing much much better
to mitigate these obstacles and i think
that creating
alternative media and message
machines is one of the most important
clearly blogs are an effort to fill that
gap
and and they've succeeded to some degree
it's still an incipient medium i mean
it's still
uh growing um in in all sorts of ways
but the imbalance is vast
and and that's just a reality but i
think that
10 15 people all the time it works but
it's nothing like having fox
a cable channel network i mean it's just
a much slower process
it seems like it'll take a long time to
be as effective
into networks or alternate media or just
following the
politico model i don't see why
progressives can't raise enough money to
do something
well i mean i mean i mean it takes a
fair amount of money
um and there's not a huge number of
people who have that kind of capital who
are willing to invest it
um and and when but but you're right i
think it's probably one of the best ways
uh to spend that sort of money i mean i
do think that you know it's important to
realize that
um even when liberal media or
progressive media outlets exist
they're still subject to the same sort
of stigmatization and
and sense that these aren't really
serious uh media i mean there are
left-wing and liberal media outlets i
mean in their magazines and their
our talk radio stations uh and their
blogs um so
there is a growing um
framework a growing structure um but the
the
imbalance is still enormous and there's
all kinds of obstacles
if ge was interested in making money
they would replicate
oberman throughout the entire network
instead of trying to keep balancing him
with opposition yeah it's amazing
that's the one show that has grown you
know amazingly
and then finally they they canceled
tucker carlson who for five years had
had no ratings at all
and there were all kinds of obvious
possibilities that
they could have used to fill that slot
you know important
um and and rising liberal personalities
rachel maddow of course was
was uh was mentioned a lot as as a
possibility she would have been superb
and the whole overman audience would
have
been a natural um might would have
naturally migrated to her show and what
did they do
they took david gregory and created
you know the four thousands you know
let's talk about the election horse race
show and and and stuck it into that um
slot so they're clearly
if it were just you know i think there's
a question do we want media is to be
driven purely by market considerations
even if you answer that question in the
affirmative
clearly that's not what's happening
because there are
there are huge gaps that are waiting to
be filled
with liberal and progressive programming
to take advantage of the kinds of
intensity
levels that we've been discussing that
just aren't being fulfilled and
one does have to ask why that is yep
i'm from san francisco and the capital
of the leadership
and i'm glad that i was here temporarily
because i had been reading your vlog
almost from the beginning long before
you went to salon
and i always thought you know it's so
funny because i've always told my
parents and friends that
i see several progressive bloggers on
the television
why keep
this is my question it's very simple how
come you're not on television more often
you're engaging and personable
i'm at the beginning of my book tour in
two weeks i'll be like that but
um
i think there's i think there's numerous
hackers i mean for one thing i've been
writing
politically only for about two years now
um and so
uh i don't i haven't tried to and don't
want to
develop um all sorts of relationships
with the people about whom i'm writing
which includes insider media insiders
and so i don't pursue that and i
actually keep a distance from that on
purpose because i want to maintain my
objectivity and i don't want to be
reluctant to criticize those who mirror
criticism that's a big part of it
the other thing is you know there are
people who have a lot of discretion
about who goes on television
and when it comes time to deciding who
that's going to be someone who spends a
fair amount of their time
singling those people out and and
hurling them out for
for pretty aggressive criticism isn't
necessarily going to be on
the top of that list i think there are
other factors
in order to go on television on those
shows you need to be willing and eager
to express yourself with great concision
to sort of
fulfill these pre-existing scripts of
conventional wisdom
and if you're willing to do that it's
pretty interchangeable who goes on if
you're writing things that don't quite
fit into that you're not going to be a
natural candidate
part of it is i don't actually want to
go on shows where i'm one of three or
four or even two
talking heads where i have 20 seconds to
answer questions for about two minutes
and then
thank you very much and because i just
think it's purposeless and a little bit
degrading
um and and finally i'm not in i spent a
lot of my time in in brazil because my
partner is brazilian
and so there are times when i do get
those invitations and i'm not able to
to accept them um just because of the
logistics um
so all those factors combine but i think
there are a lot of other ways and
probably a lot of other better ways
to find a method to have your ideas
heard and i prefer to be a little bit
patient about it and pursue
those those methods in a way that is the
least compromising
path i don't want to jump on uh msnbc
just to be on it
and then have to sort of morph into the
things that
you know i i think are so harmful so
it's a lot of different factors but um i
appreciate the question
uh two more and then we'll end yep
in many ways in terms of the big picture
you're preaching to the conversion
but my question is what can rank bio
people
do particularly if our punitive
representatives and
leadership are frankly networks i mean
that's basically what you're saying
and in many respects someone out of
touch what
can rank and final people do to try to
change some of these dynamics
well you know i mean it's interesting i
um
i was at this event this week that i
mentioned today and i'm constrained in
what i can say about it because it was
an off the record event and
and um there was a condition that i
accepted but i was able to go to this
event where there were about 20 to 25
members of congress
and a bunch of democratic consultants
and strategist types who
some of whom you would know and dislike
and um
and and the idea was well let's have a
discussion about some of the
tactics and themes of the book and about
what bloggers are doing and have to
offer
and this was not just you know the
progressive caucus the kind of people
who would be con
part of the choir some of them were you
know kind of
uh long-term moderate some of them were
freshmen who are
still a little bit teetering about what
they're going to be some were actually
blue dogs
who had voted in favor of or against the
house fisa bill because they wanted to
vote for the
rockefeller cheney one and they were
incredibly receptive
not in the politically artificial way of
pretending to be
but they stayed for a couple of hours um
i was you know as blunt
and and and emphatic as i could possibly
be as i am on my blog when i was talking
to their
to to their faces about what i thought
they were doing that was so
counterproductive
and they wanted to know uh what
blogs have to offer how they can work
better with bugs because they're
starting to realize
that the path down which they've been
marching behind these beltway democratic
strategists is a path of failure
and they've become increasingly open to
interacting with people
outside of the beltway into realizing
that blogs are a great resource
because what blogs are is a mechanism
for
citizens to work cooperatively in order
to make themselves heard and so
you know when um just a couple weeks ago
i was writing about
a the speech that the attorney general
gave uh where he made all sorts of false
claims about 9 11 and i wanted lee
hamilton the vice chair of the 911
commission to go on the record to say
that what the attorney general had said
about the 911 commission about the 9 11
attack was false
and i called lee hamilton's office and
uh he spoke i spoke to his
representative he first he said he
wouldn't comment because he didn't hear
the speech
then i said well i'm happy to send the
speech to you i have audio of the speech
you can listen to it how about
commenting then
he said no i'm not going to comment on
it because i didn't hear the speech and
i said never and they basically
said no he's never going to comment and
on my blog i you know encourage people
to write emails to
um to congressman hamilton um
encouraging him in their own words and
and passionately but civilly to comment
and he was deluged with emails and i
know that because
i was and a lot of them were cc to me um
and several days later i was contacted
by his office
and they said he has a comment and the
comment was that what the attorney
general said was something that was
completely unfamiliar to him that helped
to spawn
the controversy further to the point
where now it's an ongoing controversy
and so that kind of activism when it is
focused and and done constructively
and in a coordinated way can make a
difference the same thing happens when
that energy is directed to individual
reporters who then modify their behavior
they and and the members of congress who
were there last night
are very well aware of the criticism
that we all collectively voice
about what they're doing and they are
sensitive to it they're concerned by it
about it they're disturbed by it
everything that that you're not sure
about when you're doing it in terms of
if it's being heard it is being heard
because numbers are are loud and
effective
and i think that kind of collective
action in a in a slow
and gradual and incremental way though a
very
real way can make a difference in and is
making a difference
um yep last one over there
that they need to be applied equally
consistently to the right
i'm wondering is there a concern that
five years down the road ten years down
the road by taking up this venture and
an unintended consequence of that might
be that you create a network
uh a coordinated network which then may
mutate into some kind of a
a monster that you might not be able to
control like like the religious right
um something that 20 years from now is
gonna it's gonna make make
make this side look really really bad
right i think it's a really
good question um and and it's a very
real concern
um and and i guess the way that i would
address it is this in an ideal world
um i mean i i would love to be able to
go on to the computer every day and
write about purely sublime issues i mean
i would love to be able to sit there
um and write about why the defenses
that the administration has offered to
their law breaking with regards to
surveillance
are completely frivolous and have people
read what i'm writing
and judge them on the merits or write
about why telecom amnesty
is so unjust and eviscerates the rule of
law or about why
our policy in iraq has been so
irrational and contradictory
and have those debates and to the
exclusion of all others but that isn't
the world that we live in
and and you can make those arguments all
you want and until you address those
personality concerns
um and these kind of defamatory attacks
and
and and degrading drudge-like uh themes
none of that is going to matter and so
yeah there is a risk that if you start
engaging in that
those tactics purely to neutralize them
that you can kind of get addicted to
them if they start working
and create a monster um on among
opponents of the right that turns into
sort of a replica
of all the parts of things about the
right that that we all dislike
that is a concern um but i think the
risk of that happening
um is vastly outweighed by what will
happen if that isn't done which is that
the right will continue to win elections
and will continue to be a country that
lives under the rule
of of this very radical faction
you know i have concerns that if
democrats take over
the white house this year as i hope they
do and maintain and enlarge their
control of both houses of congress that
that kind of monopoly
on political power will mean that some
of the excesses that we've seen over the
last eight years
in republican hands will transfer to
democratic hands i mean i'm concerned
about that as well
but to me the risk of that happening is
vastly outweighed by the risk of
allowing the right wing to continue to
be in political power
and i'll deal with that risk is the way
i think about it at least at the time
if and when it happens which is then
i'll start working against that
as well um and that i think is is the
best answer at least that i can give
to your question um so i think we're
going to conclude
uh the um the discussion
and i again i really appreciate
everybody coming the questions were
great which makes
everything really um interesting and and
um
and provocative for me and so i'm really
happy about that and thankful for that
i think i'm going to be doing a book
signing i don't know where um but
i i'll be doing that somewhere right
after this is done and if you want to
just chat or
talk or whatever feel free to stay
around and we'll do that too
thank you very much
glenn greenwald is a former
constitutional law attorney
he's now a contributing writer at salon
his political reporting and analysis
have appeared in the new york times the
washington